CORRESPONDENT BILL WEIR JOINS US
NOW.
WHAT DOES LEARNING TO LIVE WITH
FIRE MEAN FOR THE COMMUNITIES
OUT WEST THAT FREQUENTLY
EXPERIENCE THESE FIRES?
>> IT'S COMING TO GRIPS WITH THE
IDEA THAT FIRE SEASON IS NOW
YEAR-ROUND, BURNING IN PLACES
TYPICALLY WHERE IT WOULDN'T, IN
WETLANDS AND TUNDRA AREAS, HIGH
ELEVATION, ALPINE, ROCKIES
BURNING LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
IT'S COMING TO EMBRACE
INDIGENOUS WISDOM.
THE NATIVE AMERICANS WHO LEARNED
TO LIVE WITH FIRE AS A NATURAL,
NEEDED PART OF NATURE, AS VITAL
AS RAIN.
ALL OF THAT WAS SORT OF
SUPPRESSED SINCE THE PIONEERS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE BUILT
DEVELOPMENTS IN THESE WILDERNESS
INTERFACES MAKING THEM SUPER
VULNERABLE.
THE ONLY THING THAT CAN BE DONE
IS TO FORTIFY THOSE COMMUNITIES,
ZONING LAWS, AND REALLY
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC ABOUT
CLEARING BRUSH AROUND THE HOUSE,
TRYING TO GET FIREPROOF GUTTERS
AROUND THE HOUSE AND TRYING TO
PREVENT THEM AS BEST YOU CAN.
AT THIS POINT THERE'S SO MUCH
FUEL OUT THERE, LIGHTNING,
SPARKS FROM A FLAT TIRE, GRIM
EMBERS, THEY'RE GOING TO HAPPEN
MORE FREQUENTLY.
>> WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EFFORTS TO
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE, OFTEN
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE PRICE TAG
OF THE LEGISLATION BEING
PROPOSED.
IN THE UNITED STATES ALONE,
HOWEVER, THE COST OF FIGHTING
THESE FIRES, JUST THESE FIRES,
HAS SHOT UP TO $1.9 BILLION JUST
LAST YEAR, MORE THAN A 170%
INCREASE OVER THE PREVIOUS
DECADE.
ARE THERE ANY SIGNS THAT
LAWMAKERS ARE GRASPING THE
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES OF DOING
NOTHING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE?
>> YOU'RE SEEING IT ON THE LOCAL
LEVELS IN COUNTIES IN NORTHERN
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA, AROUND
PARADISE THERE.
YES, WE'RE IN A STATE, ALSO,
WHERE PRIVATE FIREFIGHTING IS A
BOOMING INDUSTRY BECAUSE THE
PUBLICLY FINANCED LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES, CAL FIRE CAN'T
KEEP UP.
IF BOTH TOWNS ARE BURNING, WHO
DOES IT?
THIS TAKES A WHOLE NEW MIND
SHIFT.
A LOT OF THAT WILL BE LED BY
INSURANCE MARKETS WHERE THEY'RE
REDRAWING THE WAY CITIES ARE
ZONED.
IF THEY SAY, I'M SORRY, IT'S TOO
DANGEROUS, IT'S TOO FIRE-PRONE,
YOU'LL HAVE TO COVER YOUR OWN
RISK, THAT WILL MAKE PEOPLE
CHANGE THEIR WAYS.
>> THAT'S JUST THE ECONOMIC
COST.
FIRES ARE OBVIOUSLY INCREDIBLY
HARMFUL TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
A RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT
INCREASES IN DUST AND SMALL
PARTICLES FROM WILDFIRE SMOKE IN
2020 LED TO A SURGE IN COVID
CASES AND DEATHS IN CALIFORNIA,
OREGON AND WASHINGTON.
SO HOW SHOULD PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
FIRE-PRONE AREAS PROTECT
THEMSELVES HEALTHWISE?
>> THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LIKE THE
ANSWER.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S MASKS.
MY LITTLE BOY WAS A PANDEMIC
BABY AND WE COULDN'T FIND MASKS
TO GO INTO DELIVERY, BUT I
REMEMBER I HAD ONE FROM COVERING
THE FIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
AS MY BOY WAS BORN, IT WAS A
FIRE MASK.
SADLY, AS WE MOVE OUT OF
PANDEMIC, THAT MAY BE THE NORMAL
IN THIS WORLD THEY'RE
DESCRIBING.
PEOPLE WHO LIVED IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALL THE WAY UP TO
SEATTLE AND VANCOUVER SAW HOW
THE SKIES OUT THERE TURNED THIS
BLADE RUNNER ORANGE THERE OOCHS.
THAT PARTICULATE MATTER, EVEN
THE ONES YOU CAN'T SEE FROM AIR
POLLUTION KILLS MILLIONS A YEA